- Ooh, dude, look at that.
Look at that.
The Falcon.
They are gassing.
Get that.
Ooh, that thing is wicked.
[horn]
Hey, you mind if we
talk about your Falcon?
That's cool.
Oh, that is definitely
my kind of car.
Whoo.
This is bad-ass.
- Hi, guys.
- How are doing, man.
How are you doing?
I'm Ryan.
I'm Don.
So you guys are
cruising the hood?
- Yeah.
- Looking for cars?
Looking for cars.
You crossed our path
like go get it, get it,
we've got to get that.
This is a bad ass Falcon.
This is '61.
I had a '63 when I
was in high school.
So when I saw this
I had to get it.
Whoo.
Yeah.
Drivers began muscling up and
racing Ford Falcons turning
them into gassers
almost immediately
after their debut in 1959.
Their light, strong, build made
it perfect for the drag strip.
Ford took the hint
and started designing
the Falcon with racing in mind.
By the time the 1961
model hit the floor,
it came with a bigger engine
and an additional sport model
making it even more
attractive to buyers
who were interested in only
one thing, performance.
Can we pop the
hood on this bad boy?
We've got to see the
motor on this thing.
- Pop the hood.
- Certainly.
This is either a
327, or it's a 350.
I've been told both by
two different mechanics.
- Right.
- Same block.
It's nice because
it's still warm.
[laughter]
- This is a real gasser.
I mean it's got a
straight axle, it's got
the short stack headers on it.
And this thing is
a four speed car.
This is a true gasser.
This is a race car.
Yep.
Man.
I took it up to
the strip, it was
probably about three years ago.
I was getting about 12,1,
12,2 at a quarter mile.
Shoo, that's cooking.
This thing had to have
been fun in the drag strip?
Oh, it was.
Yeah, it was.
Because it was one or two cars
out of 300 that was old school.
Right.
The drag strip these days,
you're not going to see
too many gassers out there.
Everything is a new car.
Fuel injection, right
out of the factory.
- Those aren't fun.
- Oh, no.
You got this for what?
- 14.
- 14?
- Yeah.
- Wow.
You going to make me an offer?
[laughter]
Well, hey, come
down to the shop.
I'm sure Danny would
love to check it out.
- Yeah, I'll do it.
- Oh, please, man.
Yeah.
That would be very cool.
All right.
I'll open the second header.
You guys can hear
it when I take off.
Man, this car is cool as hell.
But I have no idea
what to offer this guy.
So he wants to sell it, he needs
to bring it down to the shop
and talk to the boss
man because he's
the one with the checkbook.
[reeving engine]
- Oh, man.
[laughter] Here we go!
Stand that bad boy up.
Yeah.
That is bad ass.
That's a bad car right there.